vail ruralité c'est l'heure tout de
suite de notre seconde et va dans ce
sens public vous le savez débat en
profondeur pour analyser les grands
thèmes de l'élection présidentielle ou
un phénomène de société ce soir la
violence contre les élus 300 plainte
pour menaces de mort depuis l'entrée en
vigueur du pass sanitaire début juillet
des agressions en hausse + 47 % sur les
onze premiers mois de l'année 2021 les
chiffres du ministre de l'intérieur sont
inquiétants jérôme ravier
flambée impressionnante et un contexte
explosif qui inquiète les violences
contre les élus ont atteint en 2020 des
records avec une hausse de presque 50 %
sur les onze premiers mois de l'année et
1186 est lui pris pour cible interrogé
au sénat aujourd'hui marlène schiappa a
confirmé que les parlementaires et les
maires en étaient les premières victimes
ce sont 160 deux parlementaires et 605
maires ou adjoints qui ont été victimes
d'atteintes volontaires à l'intégrité
physique et je veux dire que derrière
ces chiffres il ya des réalités des vies
et des dits qu'ils font vivre la
démocratie et je crois que défendre
l'intégrité des élus est fondamental de
débats oui la controverse oui la
violence la menace jamais le dernier
épisode date il ya à peine quelques
jours avec ces images terribles du
député de saint pierre et miquelon ciblé
devant son domicile par des opposants au
pass sanitaire au sénat depuis longtemps
on est mobilisé sur le sujet pour la
délégation aux collectivités locales il
faut désormais que chaque acte soit
reconnu et suivie de sanction une
reconnaissance d'une agression cela il
doit pas y avoir d'impunité une
insouciance ou d'indifférence c'est une
agression il doit y avoir une plainte il
doit y avoir une réaction
être implacables pour moi c'est ça ça
veut pas dire qu'on va emprisonner tous
les gens commettent des agressions mais
il doit y avoir une réaction face à la
flambée des violences mais aussi des
menaces sur les réseaux sociaux le
président de l'assemblée nationale
richard ferrand annonce sa volonté que
l'institution accompagne les députés qui
portent plainte et se constitue
systématiquement partie civile une
manière de les placer sous protection de
la république quelle que soit leur
couleur politique
et on analyse ces chiffres de violence
contre les élu-es une flambée inédite je
vais poser la question à mes invités
isabelle sommier bonsoir un soin et à
muse est enseignante chercheuse en
sociologie politique à l'université
panthéon sorbonne et vous publiez
violences politiques en france de 1986 à
nos jours c'est aux presses de sciences
po paris jérôme bascher bonsoir bonsoir
sénateurs l air de l'oise vous avez vous
même été menacé vous nous raconterez
comment c'est le cas également de
bernard denis et maire de saint côme du
mont dans la manche qui est avec nous en
visioconférence vous soutenez emmanuel
macron depuis 2000 16v été victime d'une
agression votre domicile le mois dernier
j'accueille également martial foucault
bonsoir soit venu professeur à sciences
po directeur du cevipof
vous avez publié sept en 2020 mère au
bord de la crise de nerfs aux éditions
de l'aube et matthieu croissandeau est
toujours à mes côtés évidemment vos
témoignages d'élus pour pour commencer
je démarre avec vous jérôme bascher
qu'est que vous est-il arrivé comme
d'autres parlementaires de l'oise moi je
suis parlementaire et là il ya des
parlementaires la réplique en marche
mais il ya exactement quatre députés
trois sénateurs qui nous avons reçu à
priori du même envoie une lettre en
disant avec une cartouche de 22 long
rifle qui est dit sur le pass
vous avez vous n'étiez pas présent voilà
à l'assemblée ou au sénat vous n'étiez
pas présent vous ne défendez pas les
libertés la peau de la prochaine sera
pour vous voilà
bon ça me perturbe pas plus que ça je du
sang froid sénatoriales si vous voulez
mais c'est allé plus loin pour mon
collègue députée de la réplique en
marche pascal bois qui lui s'est fait
cramer sa voiture dans la nuit à son
domicile
il a été réveillé par les pompiers des
mots explicites ont été
taguées sur son mur a donc il ya des
gens pour lesquels ça devient beaucoup
plus sérieux mais je prépare lui aussi
du maire de verberie michel arnould qui
a été agressé plusieurs fois par sans
doute
justice fait son travail dans kate mais
par des des jeunes qui s'adonnaient un
peu un trafic de produits stupéfiants ou
et oui ça existe aussi il ya dix
ans chez eux en brûlant maisons et dont
ils peuvent cramer clairement brûlés
vifs où on parle sa crème ça ne rendront
pas brûlé vif bien sûr c'est pas juste
une petite menace je dirais presque une
cartouche est évidemment vous vous
faites voilà vous on le voit même votre
attitude quoi vous faites preuve de
sérénité mais quand même le bleu passe
vaccinale il est examinée en ce moment
au sénat est ce qu au moment de voter
pardon de questions presque intime n'y a
pas un moment où vous allez penser à
cette à ce courrier que vous allez
reçoit vous avez reçus dont nos deux
communes et gérard larcher on à la
sérénité vieilles troupes en a vu
d'autres on en verra d'autres et c'est
d'ailleurs le sujet de l'hémicycle c'est
d'un sujet qui souvent bien méconnu
c'est pourquoi dans l'hémicycle le
public n'a pas accès directement aux
parlementaires pourquoi tout est
contrôlé à l'entrée c'est pour pouvoir
voter et délibérée dans la plaine
sérénité mais pour être dans la plaine
sérénité et aujourd'hui c'est les mêmes
sujets s'il faudrait pas qu'on s'en
prenne à votre domicile dans le même
temps envoyé oui ou à votre famille ce
qui est étonnant c'est que les
cartouches dans le cas de l'oise ont été
envoyés au domicile de chacun d'entre
nous parlementaire forcé pas public
votre adresse or notre adresse n'est pas
publique et les gendarmes ont mis un peu
de temps à la trouver bon donc vous
voyez que c'était donc un acte délibéré
conscients qu'ils demandent un petit
travail donc j'espère que toute peine
mérite salaire mais en l'occurrence que
ça mériterait une petite peine ouais et
écrire et clank aide va avancer
bernardoni vous êtes maire depuis depuis
2000 20 depuis dernier scrutin un
soutien du président la république je le
disais vous étiez sur la liste à l'ère
des mots aux dernières élections
régionales en normandie je voudrais là
aussi entendre votre témoignage que vous
est il arrivé dans la nuit du 6 au 7
décembre dernier
oui bonsoir à tous et effectivement à 2
heures du matin j'entends un robot il ya
une explosion ben voila c'était en fin
de compte tenu de ma voiture qui ont
éclaté quand je me suis levé j'ai vu
qu'il y avait des incendies donc dans
mon garage c'est donc je me suis vite
levé je suis sorti et puis j'ai réveillé
d'abord mon épouse et puis voilà
effectivement
j'ai pu faire le constat que les deux
voitures étaient étaient en feu un
troisième véhicule que j'ai pu sortir et
c'est quand je suis revenu de déposer ma
voiture que mon épouse m'a dit regarde
sur le mur ce qui est écrit et puis
effectivement donc il y avait des tags
ont menacé de mort on demandait à ce que
zemmour devienne président voilà avec
une référence directe à la candidature
d'eric zemmour un petit poème
d'orthographe mais bref
cessez whisky qu'est ce qu'ils disent
est précisément ces tags et donc il y
avait un lien est ce qu'un lien direct
et effet dans votre esprit avec la crise
sanitaire puisqu'on va démarrer ce débat
vraiment sur 7 sur cette question là
puis après on élargira évidemment aux
différentes formes de violence contre
les juges
je ne peux pas vous dire s'il ya un lien
avec la crise sanitaire ce qui était
marqué c'est que je le maire soutient
macro nous avions une semaine avant créé
le comité de soutien pour la candidature
de manuel macron pour les
présidentielles donc est-ce que c'est
plutôt ça qui pour cette raison qui a
été visée quoi je pense que c'est plutôt
pour ça que pour la pour le que pour le
vaccin quoi il avait soumis et comment
vous vous analysez et là je suis
vraiment sur la question des antilles
vexante dans quelle mouvance la violence
des antilles vagues peut-être ce
s'inscrire d'après vous alors vous me
posez une petite colle pas si facile
parce que on en parlait tout à l'heure
en coulisses il n'y a pas encore de
recherches et d'études sociologiques sur
les antilles vax et anti passants qui
sont deux populations sensiblement
différent autant alors dans les antilles
vax c'est assez hétéroclite
beaucoup de personnes profil
complotistes conspirationnistes avec un
entrisme assez fort quand même tu
étroite des droites radicales ou des
profils qui peuvent être assez proche
des gilet jaune calme en terme de deux
diplômes de catégories sociales
plutôt populaires ou moyennes
inférieures beaucoup dans la ruralité ça
c'est une question qui est qui est
importante dans l' enquête de la
fondapol et la fondation jean jaurès en
montré que 70 % des antilles passe se
disait proche des gilet jaune alors ça
c'est un grand ensemble mais il ya un
autre petit ensemble beaucoup plus petit
et sans doute pas ceux qui passent à
l'acte qui relève plutôt du phénomène je
dirais postis pillant néoruraux
médecines parallèles etc on le voit dans
la géographie d'ailleurs en de la
vaccination qui est moindre dans le sud
de la france en qui est un territoire
traditionnellement
irrédentistes rahmouna beaucoup joué sur
l'opposition paris marseille en donc se
jouer là aussi un rapport au territoire
et à ce qui est vu comme une caste
politique qui est très importante mais
c'est aussi des territoires ou des
néoruraux se sont implantés depuis des
décennies où il ya beaucoup
d'agriculture bio beaucoup de recours
aux médecines parallèles pour donner un
exemple lorsqu'il ya eu une résurgence
de l'épidémie de rougeole en 2011 eh
bien le département qui avait été le
plus touché est l ariège par exemple
martial foucault si on est plus sur une
analyse politique et peut-être que votre
début de réponse sera un peu la même
s'il n'ya pas encore toutes les données
pour répondre est ce qu'il ya une une
porosité extrême droite anti vaccins par
exemple
en préambule effectivement il n'ya pas
encore dans quelle sérieuses qui
permettent de répondre et c'est avec une
décision pour chercher réponse malgré
cela et en gironde on a quand même un
certain nombre peut-être de travaux dans
d'autres pays elle a des mouvements
aussi de contestation pas simplement
contre le pass sanitaires ou le pass
vaccinale mais davantage contre la
légitimité ou l' expertise scientifique
et effectivement il ya une vraie
polarisation politique et sans le
découvre dans d'autres pays notamment
aux états unis ou au brésil on voit
effectivement ce sont les franges les
plus radicales sur un continuum
politique qui exprime par des moyens qui
sont pas forcément comparable à ce qu'on
observe aujourd'hui en france mais
qu'ils sont
j'allais dire en tête des contestations
alors maintenant pour répondre
précisément à votre question je
si vous voulez la polarisation politique
autour de ceux de cette contestation
contre le pass vaccinale aujourd'hui sur
les éléments que l'on peut observer
c'est très compliqué très compliqué de
dire très clairement c'est tel
radicalisme à l'extrême gauche ou à
l'extrême droite alors ce qu'on peut
dire certainement c'est qu'il n'y a pas
de radicalisme au centre ça c'est ça
c'est évident mais mine de rien c'est
important parce que ça veut bien dire
que se construit aujourd'hui une
opposition contre cette mesure
d'ailleurs c'est très compliqué de dire
c'est c'est purement conjoncturelle
ouais moi je suis vraiment dans
l'incapacité de vous dire que ça a été
l'élément déclencheur parce que pour
qu'il y ait une telle crise de
contestation il faut qu'il ya un élément
déclencheur et je pense que c'est une
accumulation une forte accumulation à la
fois conjoncturelles deux ans de crise
qu vide avec des mesures à la fois
cumulative nez de plus en plus
restrictive et en même temps en jédir et
il ya il n'y a quand même dans cette
dans ce moment un début qui pour moi je
situe autour d'eux voilà de l'hiver 2018
avec le mouvement gilet jaune qui a
construit cette banalisation et à 7
continue et d'une violence de part et
d'autre d'ailleurs de part et d'autre un
patient des mandats citoyens en colère
une banalisation de la violence parfois
dans le débat public d'autre de la
violence verbale pour commencer à chaque
souffle le niveau du débat public s'est
abaissée alors ça serait pas vue la
semaine dernière voilà c'est ça toujours
été violent la politique il ya toujours
des invectives on s'est toujours pris à
partie mais là on est quand même sur des
sulfures des mots qui sont
très violents l'afld la phrase du
président la république on y reviendra
est très gênante le la phrase de valérie
pécresse il utilisait le mot de kärcher
sarkozy s'est aussi violent et il ya une
banalisation de la violence politique
aussi alors est-ce que c'est lié je vais
pas faire du tout procès des réseaux
sociaux mais le fait de penser dans des
clusters idéologique fermé vous a
l'impression de tous penser pareil et
que tous les autres sont des ou
tous les autres sont et alors là dans
les réseaux sociaux dieu sait qu'on peut
insulter parfois sous couvert d'anonymat
ou pas et le passage à l'audience
physique moi j'ai été très surpris on
s'en était pris aux symboles juillet
quelques temps aux souvenirs
autour des bonnets rouges essaye mais
des révoltes fiscales en beauté un peu
jacquerie ont démonté les portiques mais
avec les jets les jaunes on s'en est
pris aux symboles du pouvoir la
préfecture puis anglais les volontés de
monter sur les lisières il fait lui-même
également auprès d'un public et puis le
parlementaire déjà c'est à qui a eu déjà
des agressions de parlementaires parce
qu'ils représentaient la majorité parce
qu'il représentait le pouvoir en place
au moment des jaunes donc c'est devenu
une espèce de réflexe enfin de réflexion
il faut quand même pas exagérer mais de
deux débouchés naturels pour soi d'aider
des gens très radicaux soient des gens
très marginaux mais en tout cas c'est
maintenant c'est maintenant courant on
est passé de la colère à la violence ça
avant dé certains groupes de politiques
disent aimer votre colère est légitime
c'était une façon toujours d'être
empathique votre colère est légitime
donc là on commence par la colère et
puis après bah oui mais la cause de la
colère on peut passer un acte violent
pas très pas très compliqué comme comme
raisonnement est donc la violence
devient légitime pour certains violence
verbale effectivement les réseaux
sociaux ont mis toutes les paroles au
même niveau les politiques je le déplore
et moi même je suis sans doute pas
exempt de reproches mais on essaie
examine aujourd'hui de ce calme et
peut-être pas mettre un peu apaisées le
système mais il est certain que tout
cela crée une violence verbale et puis
après de la violence verbale vous passez
à la violence physique si vous n'êtes
pas habituellement au dialogue j'ai
juste reprendre un point j'ai reçu mois
neuf anti pacs avec m'ont demandé de
devenir orient n'avait rapidité 9
c'était déçu que j'avais reçu déjà
qu'ils étaient gilet jaune et je trouve
qu après avoir reçu le courrier dans ton
c'était avant avant de mémoire c'était
avant ou après j'aurai avait fixé la
date avant je ne sais plus bon j'avais
fixé la date à vos problèmes on peut
être dans le dialogue il faut là j'ai
des options qui peuvent être différentes
mais voilà on entend les uns et les
autres on peut d dialoguer avec eux il
faut aussi leur proposer de les voir et
de les recevoir et je fais juste une
parenthèse cette violence elle est
d'autant plus légitime elle est un
débouché politique d'autant plus
légitime qu'il ya des politiques de
premier plan qui disent aux gens vous
vivez dans une dictature vous êtes
privés de vos libertés vous êtes privés
de vos droits appel à la résistance on
entend ou d'autres gens qu'ils ont vu
dans un apartheid la loi et de tous les
bords que ce soit à droite l'extrême
droite ou à l'extrême gauche on entend
ces paroles là et donc il ya des gens
chauffé à blanc qui finissent par passer
à l'acte alors le thème de notre débat
et je voudrais qu'on y répondre
maintenant c est ce que cette flambée
est inédite je reviens aux chiffres ont
été donnés par gérald darmanin
sur donc je rappelle c'est sur les onze
premiers mois de l'année
1186 agressions contre les élus années
2000 21 évidemment c'est plus 47% par
rapport à 2020 ça continue
malheureusement en ce début d'année
puisqu'on parle de 60 élus menace est
toujours source ministre ministère de
l'intérieur 1 depuis de le début 2022 et
puis je rappelle c'est 300 plainte pour
menaces de mort là c'est depuis juillet
2021 c'est à dire le la mise en place du
pass
sanitaires isabelle sommier pour votre
livre vous remonter jusqu'en 1986 est ce
que ces chiffres sont exceptionnels
est-ce que la violence politique que
l'on vit est pire que la pire de ces
quarante dernières années n'ont pu que
cela on ne ment pas certainement pas
alors effectivement il ya un décalage
entre la réalité du phénomène et la
perception et sa perception si on
regarde on terme de d'épisodes de
violence militante on a étudié sur les
indépendantistes les idéologique etc on
ne retrouve pas le pic des années 89 90
pic du haut aux indépendantistes corses
ans qui sur l'ensemble de la période
ouvrez 50% étaient responsables de 50%
des des faits de violence et rejette oui
bien sûr mais enfin je vous
dise titien à suez de base excusez-moi
de formation je trouve que c'est un
raccourci qui me semble un peu rapide 10
on a travaillé on va comparer des
particuliers et
non
classés on peut tout à fait prendre le
choix en de travailler sur les violences
au nom d'une cause politique je ne vois
pas en quoi ce serait se serait
illégitime ans donc on n'a pas une
montée de la violence comme on peut des
fois le croire et c'était d'ailleurs
l'enjeu de cette base de données qui
travaille quand même sur 6000 fait donc
six mille épisodes de violence n'est pas
rien
menacés ou autant d'agressions contre
les élèves rien au niveau annonça au
niveau des agressions il ya
effectivement une remontée ça il n'y a
pas de doute là dessus on voit une
remontée à partir de 2016
ça très très clairement et une élévation
des seuils de violence dans le sens où
on a au départ plutôt des dégradations
de deux locaux parlementaires et cetera
ans alors les premiers ce sont les gilet
jaune effectivement pour un tiers les
seconds se sont responsables de ces
phénomènes ce sont les agriculteurs dans
le cadre de la campagne contre le ceta
par exemple mais progressivement
effectivement on a des atteintes aux
biens et progressivement se rapproche
des élus avec une atteinte par exemple
au domicile aux véhicules
très très peu très peu
d'agressions mais ces agressions très
clairement elles sont en augmentation
des chiffres officiels 346 agression
d'élus d'après le ministère de
l'intérieur en 2018 lorsque le sénat
fait une enquête de victimation auprès
des maires en là on est en 2019 et bien
80 % des mères sondés disent avoir été
victimes
d'intimidation
d'insultés voire d'agressions mais les
agressions c'est 14% d'entre eux alors
il ya un chiffre qui est très
intéressant et bon je vais pas vous
assommer de chiffres c'est que sur ces
14 % donc rousset 543 élus qui avaient
été agressées physiquement
dans huit cas sur dix ces deux ans des
toutes petites communes ce qui veut dire
qu'on a deux types de phénomènes un
phénomène de violence comme ça colérique
d'un administré et ce qui est nouveau et
qui se développe effectivement là on le
voit avec le mouvement des antilles vax
c'est des phénomènes de groupe et là
c'est différent c'est ce que alors au
niveau que marcel foucault en 11 jours
donne les chiffres sur les plainte pour
menaces de mort est ce que d'après vous
ces chiffres sont sous-estimés crs kia
est ce que tous les élus menacent et
porte plainte mais est ce que je veux
dire où est ce que finalement il ya pas
mal de d'agression ou une menace qu'il
passe ter carrément sous les radars pour
toute personne victime d'une menace
d'une activation ou une agression c'est
toujours très compliqué de déclarer de
révéler et de porter plainte donc c'est
un cheminement très très longs mois je
mon intuition sur le sujet c'est que on
est probablement à une sous-estimation
du nombre réel de cas et alors ça c'est
une évolution dans le temps
si on fait un saut en arrière il ya 40
ans pour un maire victime d'une menace
ou d'une même d'une agression symbolique
pas physique déclaré qu'il a été victime
d'une telle menace c'était impensable 1
pour ça parce que ça portait atteinte à
sa légitimité à sa stature à sa position
dans sa communauté considéré presque ça
faisait partie du job est ce que vous
diriez ça peut-être pour certains mais
eux en tout cas il n'était pas question
de rendre publique cette cette menace
vis-à-vis de son autorité politique et
que je dis politique au sens premier du
terme pas au sens partisan ensuite
aujourd'hui je je je pense que parmi
tous les cas qu'ils sont
révélée est enregistrée par le ministère
de l'intérieur on a quand même faut
faire très attention parce que on peut
pas parler des mêmes logiques qui
conduisent à cette violence selon que
l'on est intimidé
via les réseaux sociaux ça a été évoqué
tout à l'heure où que l'on ait menacé
qu'on porte atteinte même à des à des
biens de la commune de mobilier urbain
un tag sur la mairie mais cet ensemble
participe à une violence à la fois
symbolique et c'est une violence
physique est donc aujourd'hui ce mois ci
le phénomène nouveau en entendant c'est
en découvrant ces chiffres c'est le
nombre de parlementaires c'est le nombre
de parlementaires parce que rapportée à
la population des parlementaires le
chiffre est très élevé donc c'est en ce
sens que je trouve que on est aussi dans
une séquence très particulière
n'oublions pas qu'on est à trois mois
d'une élection présidentielle donc il ya
une certaine manière une vraie fenêtre
d'opportunité pour aussi faire le coup
médiatiser cette contestation pas ce
vaccinale qui peut être un prétexte mais
c'est pas simplement une question
sanitaire bernard denis je reviens vers
vous
vous êtes maire depuis l'an dernier
c'est ça est ce que est ce que il ya eu
je reviens pas sur ce qui vous est
arrivé dans la nuit du 5 au 6 décembre
du 6 au 7 décembre pardon mais est-ce
que vous l'intimidation la colère d'un
administré voyez ce que je veux dire est
ce que ça ça fait partie malgré tout un
peu de votre quotidien
la colère on la voit régulièrement dans
nos petites communes 1 les gens sont
s'entraîne bien sûr à l'autorité au
maire mais même ils vont s'en prennent
ils vont s'en prendre à leurs voisins
ils vont s'en prendre voilà quoi c'est
quelque chose que l'on vit régulièrement
que moi je je je vois quoi il dans les
mots des gens lorsqu'on parle voilà ils
sont je ne sais pas pourquoi mais ils en
veulent à tout le monde enfin compte
voilà il tombe hélas la politique ils en
veulent à leur patron ils en veulent à
leur voisin à leurs collègues de travail
et ça c'est quelque chose que je ressens
de plus en plus les mères en première
ligne je vous propose une autre
démonstration tient avec un extrait de
ce reportage long format réalisé par
jérémy huntsman et gaspard flamand avec
le maire notamment 12 en côte d'or vous
en aviez certainement entendu parler et
ça avait fait la une de l'actualité
cette agression qu'il avait subi comme
on prononce ou ch pardon si la vallée
ce dimanche 2 mai 2021 jean-claude
girard s'en souvient comme si c'était
hier ils se promènent le long du canal
de bourgogne lorsqu'un pilote de quad
déboule sur la piste cyclable
je suis dit il faut pas rouler comme ça
dans la commune c'est dangereux il ya
des preneurs il ya des enfants c'est pas
raisonnable le pilote me dis tout de
suite mais qui tu es toi pour me parler
comme ça et quand je lui dis j maire de
la commune responsable de la
tranquillité publique la seule réponse
que j'ai fait j'en ai rien à je
descends je te casse la gueule la
situation s'envenime et plusieurs
individus s'en prennent à lui j'entends
quelqu'un dire fait le ter celui là et
où je prends un coin de manière certaine
un coup de pied au niveau du thorax et
un coup de barre derrière la tête et je
perd connaissance c'était quelque chose
que je n'avais jamais connu mais que
j'aurais peut-être à tort ou pas jamais
imaginé qu'il puisse ça puisse arriver
sur sur la commune un jour 9 h r qu'est
ce que ça vous inspire on sort la du
débat sur les passes sanitaire au pass
pass vaccinale c'est vraiment cette
violence un peu pas quotidienne mais qui
peut survenir contre contre les élus et
aussi contre les parlementaires je
reprends le bol programmé à juste titre
dit ce sont les maires ruraux qui sont
victimes le plus et parce que ils sont
seuls en prêt c'est ce que dit le maire
douche quand vous connaissez la côte
d'or où je sais vraiment pas dijon c'est
vraiment sur la
série et donc vous n'êtes pas sur les
coteaux ben
vous n'êtes pas du tout dans la ville
vous êtes vraiment à la campagne et vous
êtes tout seul le maire c'est l'autorité
seuls or
nul n'est besoin ici d'expliquer qu'il
ya une crise de l'autorité est donc le
maire officier de police judiciaire
officiellement à ces écrits ça ne sert à
rien ces dessins d'une autorité
fantoches
il n'est pas là mais beaucoup de mairies
aujourd'hui de petites communes
s'équipent de caméras pour la secrétaire
de mairie qui se fond qui se font elles
mêmes à gré c'est parfois juste
verbalement mais un peu secoué on va
dire à tous rarement physiquement mais
on en est là on en est là les maires me
dise voilà on est obligé de faire ça
pour protéger la secrétaire de mairie
donc ce n'est pas uniquement les élus
mais si vous n'avez pas de filtre des
services produits grandes villes
c'est un poème sur les parlementaires
vous avez l'impression de toucher les
gens d'en haut en étant bas on va dire
les choses comme ça c'est vous la au
fait remonter vous savez c'est ce que
disent nos concitoyens est remonté c'est
ce qu'on essaye de faire d'ailleurs aux
questions d'actualité bien souvent mais
par des courriers safar pas d'autre
métier quoi
ils touchent les gens d'en haut quand
vous allez attaquer un parlementaire aux
impressions d'agresser presse le
président la république je voudrais en
général pas le nom de votre député très
peu de gens le connaissent aussi le
connaissent au moins ils l'ont jamais vu
pour beaucoup la plupart d'entre eux
donc c'est juste une façon d'approcher
le symbole est de dire je m'attaque aux
prises en appui qui est celui que je
vois la télévision finalement j'en passe
take two a t'elle ministre qui ne
revient pas et donc c'est juste un
filtre mars est horrible comme pour le
filtre et le sugen la démocratie
représentative et l'eau or it et nous
devrions reprise à l'heure et je suis
plus d'autorité c'est je reviens sur
cette idée d'autorité il avait soumis
est ce que est ce que dans la violence
dont on parle dans ce dans ce débat
cette violence malgré tout en
recrudescence on l'a on l'a bien compris
dans les agressions contre les élus est
ce que c'est ce principe d'autorité
finale manquée
en cause qui est balayée depuis des
années d'après je pense que il ya des
situations très variables angle
différent ententois la situation qu'on
vient d'entendre et puis d'éphédrine
plus collectif ans mais très clairement
on est dans une société toute façon qui
est un peu au bord de la crise de nerfs
si je puis dire en et les anti vaccins
je parle de ce que je connais et dans
les antilles vax et les gilet jaune il
ya des carburants des thématiques et des
carburants qui sont assez semblables et
s'ouvre sur fond quand même deux crises
majeures
de la démocratie représentative
le sentiment de ne plus être représenté
cette vision d'une caste politique d'une
restriction des libertés également la
question de la dérive des liberticide
apparaît avec les gilets jaunes et pas
seulement sa date au moins 2016 mais
très présente chez les anti vaccins le
sentiment de mépris également en est
hélas on en revient on l'évoquait tout à
l'heure en au rôle des td des phrases
des phrases qui blessent en sentiment de
ne plus d'être considérés comme des
citoyens de seconde zone ou ignorer que
ça c'est d'autant plus paradoxal que
cette assemblée enfin je parle de
l'assemblée nationale elle a d'une
certaine façon jamais autant étaient
diverses par rapport à ce qu'elle était
avant n'a jamais autant ressemblé aux
français on sait qu'il ya eu un grand
changement au qu'on soit d'accord ou pas
d'accord avec avec la politique menée
par la majorité actuelle mais dans les
profilés ou à des professionnels des
politiques c'est beaucoup de gens issus
de la société civile qui avait des
métiers qui ont tenté et qui sont
souvent aujourd'hui les premiers
intimider et les premiers frappés au
moment où il s'interroge est-ce que je
vais poursuivre la politique est ce que
je vais me représenter aux législatives
moi je le sais pour en avoir discuté
avec certains qui existent quand on se
reçoit soit des balles soit des lettres
d'intimidation soit qu'on se fait crever
les pneus de la voiture juste comme ça
rebondit encore que j'avais un métier
avant j'ai voulu faire la politique
d'avant leur côté
novateur ou novice en politique
disparaît derrière la figure du
président république parce que la
pratique du pouvoir très verticale de ce
pouvoir là en particulier voilà à
effacer ces différences mais pour le
coup c'est paradoxal parce que cette
assemblée n'était pas composé à la base
de professionnels de la politique telle
que vous écriviez des gens qu'on estime
faire partie d'une caste ou même
déconnecté des réalités la vision qu'ils
ont bien sûr je suis petit bémol c'est
il avait donc pas l'habitude forcément
de discuter et d'ailleurs une pratique
de discussion assez vive avec leurs 6
aussi concitoyens donc c'est j'ai tout
fait avec un système à son avantage et
il ya le revers est la mère de la
médaille alors je reviens on l'a évoqué
vous l'aviez déjà évoquée mais sur sur
les mots choisis par emmanuel macron
dans son interview au parisien
aujourd'hui en france les non-vaccinés
j'ai très envie de les emmerder pardon
de reprendre le gros mot jusqu'au bout
oui oui jusqu'au bout voilà la froide
jusqu'au bout
joue à lui ses citoyens je ne suis pas
pour le bien des français est bien là
les nouveaux accès des laiteries de
vendée effectivement il ya la question
de sont ils encore des citoyens et c'est
bon beaucoup de réactions tient à une
des dernières importante en date celle
de gérard larcher le président du sénat
c'était lundi sur france inter en
l'écoutent l'ont aidé le signe et d'une
société profondément crispé profondément
fracturé profondément divisé pour
répondre à cette violence il faut de la
fermeté mais en même temps il faut être
très attentif à ne pas fracturée à ne
pas diviser plus le pays ça veut dire
très clairement qu'il ya pas deux
catégories citoyens entre ceux qui sont
vaccinées donc je suis et moi qui prône
la vaccination est ce qu'elle est
qu'un président de la république est en
vie j'insiste sur le terme envie d'en
merdé les français je ne crois pas que
ce soit la réponse un pays qui a besoin
de retrouver une forme d'unité
bernard denis je rappelle que vous
soutenez le présent de la république at
il pris le risque de fractures et un peu
plus la société française avec cette
phrase
bah écoutez moi je vais simplement vous
répondre une chose c'est que ces gens là
qui m'ont mis le feu chez moi c'est eux
qui m'emmerde aujourd'hui parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est moi qui suis un peu
dans la galère c'est moi qui court
derrière les assurances on me faire
rembourser et donc voilà effectivement
je ne peux pas d'autres d'autres
commentaires par rapport à ce qu'a pu
dire le président mais effectivement
aujourd'hui je suis un peu dans le dur
parce que ben voilà c'est moi qui subit
aujourd'hui
oui on l'entend mais quand même je pars
parlons de vous reprenez la question
parce que je ne verse pas la
responsabilité dans les violences dont
on parle depuis le début de de ce débat
la question que je pose c'est est-ce
qu'un président de la république prend
un risque d'envenimer finalement les
débats avec une phrase comme celle là
effectivement il ya peut-être un risque
mais à un moment donné effectivement il
faut taper le point sur la table
remettent les gens là où il fallait
remettre à faire ce qu'il faut parce que
parce qu'ils sont pas vaccinés c'est eux
qui a envie qui empêche les légendes
rentre à l'hôpital pour se faire opérer
a failli à un moment donné quoi il faut
il faut avancer quoi et moi je soutiens
tout à fait ce qu'a dit le palier dans
la république
merci de ce témoignage ci si on essaye
de te tiens je jamais un autre élément
au débat si on regarde un peu ce qui se
passe à l'étranger on a appris le but
c'était ce matin oui hier que le québec
envisageait de taxer les non vaccinés
pour le coup qu'il représente pour la
société bon bref il n'ya pas qu'eux mais
y'a pas ses mots qui ont été employés
par le prêt vise québécois mais où
canadien mais il ya quand même cette
volonté d'emmerdés pardon les essais il
n'y a pas que la france le canada
prévoit même de suspendre les
allocations chômage et oui nous
donnerons accès aux cons ça fait quand
même aller alors là ça va au delà des
mots c'est dans les arts ea et puis à
singapour vous rembourser tous les frais
de santé mais encore une fois la
violence symbolique la violence verbale
de la part du chef de l'état pour moi
elle pose un problème parce que au delà
de la petite phrase qui a fait que le
débat a tourné autour de lui et que ce
le coût politique et ait réussi pendant
deux jours le buzz je veux dire c'est
c'est pas un facteur d'apaisement c'est
pas un facteur qui aujourd'hui apaise le
débat public -si président la république
ne fait pas personne de fort martial
foucault prix non c'est même c'est même
tout le contraire parce que en fait ce
dont on parle c'est moins gérer
l'expression d'une crise sociale
sanitaire on traverse une vraie crise
morale en fait ces sujets sont pour moi
touche à la moralité et autour de cette
phrase alors on peut avoir plusieurs
interprétations moi ce qui me choque
c'est pas tant le registre
orthographique ou de la grammaire qui a
mobilisé le président de la république
c'est surtout l'idée dans cette crise
morale de donner l'impression qu'une
personne a le pouvoir tient sur deux
d'embêter tel et tel groupe social c'est
cette idée même qui est contesté depuis
2018 qu'il y aurait une sorte de tête
unique qui fait et défait ce qui est bon
ou ce qui est mauvais pour une société
c'est le président de la république et
en utilisant cette formule il donne de
nouveau le sentiment qu'il a agi seul ce
pouvoir indépendamment de toute
représentation du pouvoir dépendamment
des tranchées
représentative 1 qu'il peut lui même
surseoir dsk ce qui fait donc société
pas la réalité de la vème république
tout simplement et et du régime
présidentiel depuis qu'on est passé
aucun cas là aussi mais c'est inédit
jamais un président adnot gauche là pour
brader de telle ou telle catégorie
généralement à présent c'est là pour
régler on est là on est d'accord pour
créer des problèmes c'est long c'est
robin tout le monde part je pense que
tout le monde pas on parle de
l'abaissement de la fonction
présidentielle au fur et à mesure du
temps
les uns et les autres qui ont contribué
moi je dirai les choses simplement je me
prête de droite et quel est le jour où
la pauvre con c'est de même nature je
préférais élégance de jacques chirac
moi c'est chirac face et autres danses
et un peu plus fin mais au delà de la
finesse ce n'est pas rajouter de la
violence à des mini miss notes court at
eropp on passe à autre chose mais le
fait d'être aussi obligé sans arrêt de
faire des punchlines pour parler en bon
français dorénavant un site un langage
parfois un peu trop fleuri un peu trop
populaire qui ne veut pas dire qu'il
faut être totalement abscons gojats de
le faire juste à l'instant et donc on ne
comprennent pas oui mais
on n'est pas obligé de sombrer dans une
certaine vulgarité qui incita à ce que
tout soit banalisé aussi parce que oui
vous banalisez du gouvernent le propos
est la fonction qui est la vôtre et
surtout d'un mépris de classe terrible
parce que si ça parler aux gens pour
parler aux français pour en parler
populaire il faut être julia ou aussi
c'est se fermer
kg et jaune qui roulent au diesel et qui
fument des clopes
mais il a baissé mais si on essaye
d'analyser les faits les faits de la
phrase du ch crise en république vous
avez fait à juste titre la différence
entre anti vax et anti vaccin fait ce
que finalement ça les salles et souhaite
pas d'une certaine façon on peut le
craindre en effet moi je pense que c'est
pas une phrase présidentielle c'est
plutôt une phrase de candidats d'être
pour ressouder souder son camp qui
traduit également le fait que de toute
façon ces populations ne vont pas voter
pour lui en de toute façon bon légers
jose 4 % d'entre eux qui avaient voté
pour l'actuel président au premier tour
en est donc en quelque sorte ils sont
perdus pour le candidat macro mais
effectivement du point de vue de la
fonction présidentielle ça pose un
certains problèmes et ça contribue à
l'hystérisation et à la dégradation du
débat du débat politique bien entendu
ans alors ce n'est pas le seul ans et ça
rajoute ça personnalise un problème
institutionnel ans qui est liée au
fonctionnement comme vous le signale y
est en de plus en plus monarchique de de
la vème république
donc il cristallise sur sa personne des
colères d'où cette extrême
personnification que l'on a vu avec les
gilet jaune avec l'image de marie
antoinette 2
l'imaginaire de la révolution française
sur les anti vaccins on est plus sur
l'imaginaire de la résistance en mai
effectivement c'est pas une phrase qui
est susceptible de calmer
l'énervement la colère de d'individus
ans qui se sentent ignorés parce qu'à
une véritable arche ep lisa sion 2-2
dans ce pays en est le sentiment
effectivement de ne pas nous ne pas être
écoutés et même d'être méprisés ça c'est
un mot qui revient souvent martial
foucault elle dans les premiers tout
premiers sondages
donnez plutôt un effet positif on va
dire pour pour emmanuel lincot en tout
cas sur le fond pas sur la forme avec
58% de mémoire des français qui qu'il
approuvait est ce que peut y avoir un
effet boomerang dans l'opinion d'après
vous
je ne saurais pas répondre à cette
question en revanche je vais répondre
une question qui m'est pas posée
qui consiste à dire attention vis ce
qu'on évoque là sur cette phrase et sur
l'usagé l'interprétation qu'on peut en
faire c'est une vraie somme de paradoxe
parce qu'à la fois on est perturbée
quand on analyse la situation on a des
moments depuis deux ans où on a un
président de la république une majorité
qui essaye de proposer du collectif en
disant on va prendre soin d'une société
par un certain nombre de filets de
protection
intervention de l'état très très
massives et puis tout ça y est
interrompu un moment donné avec une mise
en scène de ce qui est contesté de ce
qui est aujourd'hui montré comme la
cause de tous les problèmes une société
de plus en plus individualisée ou un
rapport de plus en plus individuelle aux
autres et alors on est on est quand même
passablement perturbée parce qu'on se
dit il ya une séquence de collectif et
d'un seul coup on est interrompue et
cette séquence format du président de la
république est une réponse à un rapport
individuel à la société et rapport aux
autres qui est terrible qui est terrible
y compris même dans une campagne
présidentielle où on dit la société
française et traversé par toute sorte de
fracture il a une quand même qui moi me
semble être extrêmement grave estime
aujourd'hui c'est ce niveau de défiance
vis-à-vis des autres pas vis-à-vis du
pouvoir politique ça c'est vrai partout
en europe bruit vis-à-vis des autres et
donc merci s'est rajouté une pièce dans
le giron que je suis de votre lit homère
au bord de la crise de nerfs c'est aux
éditions de l'aube isabelle sommier
violences politiques en france de 1990 à
nos jours c'est tout presses de sciences
po paris merci à tous d'avoir participé
à ce débat